hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Red Dead Redemption
- when we last left off we got some new
duds some new threads looking good
looking sharp I can't believe anybody
would think that I was not dressed good
but we also have new missions to go see
I know there's a lot of people Ving for
our attention right now but we've got
places to be and we got things to do let
me get my hat
oh we're about paid the down red or some
other cliche phrase like that who's
snoring why would anybody go oh you know
there are beds right uncle UNK you know
there's beds okay whatever I need to
worry about that right now anyway oh
what a beautiful day to be a bear hey
everybody how are you doing hey you good
man so nice to own land yeah whatever
hey Hosea I haven't talked to you in a
bit you still harbored and grudges still
got problems
Hosea we sure as [ __ ] better clean up a
little so we're doing this oh yeah
old friend Dutch van der Linde is
finally showing his true colors
social-climbing old Senor Bronte that
horrendous snake has invited us to the
ball Cinderella so my suggestion is we
go and get you a gown wait you're gonna
make me get clothes the second I get
clothes you're gonna make me get clothes
ruk me I just got clothes I so much
party at the mayor's house and the guest
of honor is the worst crook in town I'm
sure that we will find
well what the hell I just got close look
uh I'm afraid the mayor does not allow
guns at official functions after last
year's incident
why shouldn't hand it over here pointing
you to mr. Bronte I believe he is
expecting you at least I get to schmooze
but I'd smooths a lot man I need a
haircut shave I'll bet you on the
shoulder once I leave I'll be beautiful
okay well this is weird okay not exactly
what I was expecting but Bill Williams
and I we look so fitting in this place
so supposed to be here definitely one
under presume oh oh oh
have a good day Wow we're gonna fail
this mission just because I was in the
wrong area at the wrong time in here who
is it in here oh man I'm being played
for a fool here up there supposed to go
enjoy the party goodness Warren I was
yeah whatever I don't know what these
people are talking about and I don't
know why I'm here
but alas let's go make some contacts
let's go swoon some people hello
[Laughter]
that's this is sanity high society yes
apparently so and all these people these
are friends of yours and your brother no
not quite for quite but they certainly
are afraid of me like that one see that
wretch he's the mayor laundry Lemieux
he'll do anything for a dollar and I
mean anything
politics is a foul business oh and that
one too that is Alberto facade he owns a
sugar plantation out on the island and
he comes here to her in despoiling self
[Laughter]
Confederate Maj in the world a hero they
say this is his very young wife me young
mistress thus the natural order of
things yes but a young wife is unseemly
to get very Americans they get what they
deserve yes and the letter to the mayor
oh yeah battle savior this
self-righteous newspaper man maybe maybe
you will kill him for me one day
well we're not paid killers is such done
cold blood anyway I didn't know you were
so particular that you wouldn't help a
friend
oh I'm willing to help in any way I can
within reason I'm going to pretend to
understand what that means
I meant no offense sir
none taken well it has been wonderful
conversing with you but I can tell that
you are very busy and I won't waste any
more of your time yes yes yes go enjoy
yourselves and mingle with this vulgar
scum
it'll make you long for the days when
you could shoot each other and scoop
cows out from the open range though sure
were the days do love a good cows crew
we've not made anything well we are
going to need some money station to keep
a lot of cash there in the day now I
could not even myself use such my pairs
but you as a guest yes as my guest okay
good day good day alright boss okay I
get see it is you know alright I I'm
confused and hairy but what's in that
room there's something spicy in that
room over there let me just give it a
try make sure you locked it oh you did a
good job
oh I'm very proud of you're good at
walking Thank You ciao ciao I like that
it's good dog
let's go I like Gracie ation field gray
shaded already hello hello I'm here - me
and my beard without my hat you get a
hat boss I don't get a hat you sure
about that information okay you sure
about that boss you go find us some
place to rub go make us some new friends
[Music]
okay can do thank boss thank you
okay well that was informative and
helpful and I'm so glad that we did all
that and I'm so glad that we're here cuz
I do well at parties if there's one
thing that I do it's do well at parties
hey how you doing hey how you doing hey
hey I was doing hey I'll take that yes
please I do good at parties give me some
of that hey like you stashed glug this
down real good Woody's work baby
fancy how do you like you you'll like
them you like ties Sudha hey lady
hey man hello how are you somebody
supposed to put a cake okay alright keep
playing
come on let's get some music up in here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me too good evening to you equal what
about what about me threaten to hit me
oh no no no no no no pretty Slurpees
lips ladies
[Music]
we keep whipping the sin out of other
mr. Jameson tournament which I will not
be attending is for a game too rich for
my mother I may be a name is not a
wealthy man
I run a prison the old riverboat
tournaments of her car sharks and rich
fools a really big stakes game attracts
oil men and suchlike from all over my
pockets are not deep enough for that
wise man all right what's the matter
with you swore hey how you doing hey are
you doing
you talking to me I don't know you said
to me I couldn't hear you over the sound
of my drink
all right deal good talking you ever
guys heard of as nurple I need you are
drunk 30 no I'm not drunk you fool
but this man this man loves [ __ ] hey
you are pretty drunk
what happened to my drink I didn't I
don't know what was happened to me I
don't know what's happening
sleep it off with a broken arm where's
my Slurpee sippy okay goodbye I don't
know why I did that
okay alright alright
may I help you I'll help good where's my
champagne
I lost my sippy drink no all right I
hope you're enjoying my party
allegedly it's quite a place you got
here
it's not mine and the city is horribly
in debt but we can still put on a good
show do you know every meter we seem to
have another deranged drug on our hand
shall we wish I had my sipping drink
[Applause]
mr. Coleman was quite insistent I'm
afraid he shouted on the telephone for
several me mr. Connell is a horse's ass
and a bad horse I'm very sorry sir it's
not your fault I'm a fool for trusting
him I'll come inside in a minute make me
enjoy the fireworks fine come on a boss
you can count on me if I had my hat I'd
been worried good one got me
okay no but I want to see the fiery
words oh they're going boom rail guard
okay remain undetected I need my can I
borrow your Slurpee
anybody got slurp I'd be real stealthy
if I had my slurp whatever this follow
this guy goes wherever I'm going for
some reason bouncer of this joint
hey hope you don't mind me following you
sorry if I'm bothering you use drop
Bronte hey you got a problem with the
Bronte what's wrong with Bronte boy is
he causing problems for you I'll take
care of him a wrassle him I'll get his
arm in a headlock I'll do it in real
good did you get so far ahead of me one
time deck will do close not too far real
self no
look at me who do you think you are this
area is not meant for the likes of you
you know this what an [ __ ] what a
douchebag you look like you need to be
the unfortunate victim of a bear attack
Oh bear broke into the mayor's house so
sad ripped his servant to shreds who
could have believed it I couldn't have
the man with a nice bear hat impossible
to discern who did it
excuse all the blood dripping down my
claws Oh looks like I need to join you
in the air indecision de rêve the ledger
from the desk oh you've got it me oh
I've got this ledger very inspected Lee
but it's locking nothing easy-peasy
I like those big words I don't know what
they mean but I like them I like big
words anybody inspect a letter
I like letters I like 26 letters read
most sounds alone yet again the city is
in debt to you and I'm flabbergasted
buyers generosity excuse my accent I
don't get it quite to writing the
magnificent gift you provided will prove
to be a cornerstone in our financing of
our dream of establishing a
world-renowned university in our city we
are now well on our way to the funds
necessary to found both the Divinity
School and Humanities College future
students of annoying
a great deal to the vision of men such
as you I am forever grateful you'll find
only let me all think it did pretty good
with that one pretty sure that was
pretty accurate all right okay so that
was letter to Bronte
well I'm tell me not to trust Bronte
Bronte seems like the precursor of the
American Mafia but hey I know okay I
guess I'm here now where is here exactly
and where am I supposed to go hey boss
hey Dutch man can I call you Dutch man
hey boss got some good news for you here
bad news depending on where your
perspective is on news but I got some
kind of news here where are you why
can't I run through this place
stupid palm fronds anyway can I get my
Slurpee now oh there we go
excuse me we just have to skedaddle
through that hey boys this is waste of
time maybe not I think
gentlemen
I think we're done here
[Music]
hey but I barely got one drink big thank
real wanna me but not yet a city back
maybe and a stuff one we're gonna leave
that could be the one thing we need
there's also that trolley car station
Samuel Bronte told us about and I heard
about high-stakes poker game come on
okay
all of them sound like good things all
founds good things for us boss that
spells good luck yeah yeah okay alright
better give me my right gun back my life
all them folk also pleased with
themselves high society pigeon [ __ ] if
you ask me it's more like torch well
that sword at the point then let the
people torture themselves hears them
papers that hears them paper balls they
see you take this now thanks no wait I
might have an idea let me think
you do the thinking real good boss
that's what you best at boss I love you
boss love you for your big thinking
brain your huge throbbing brain is so
incredible boss I wish I had half the
brain you did boss boss Oh interesting
time yes so what's next
dancing less deportment more along the
lines of armed robbery
Hosea's handling reconnaissance on the
bank he and Abigail are gonna run some
distractions see how the law react good
oh and I spoke to Evelyn Miller fine man
here helping the Indian chief we saw
yeah I met him too with the mayor he's
lobbying officials and sanding me on
their behalf maybe we could help maybe
now I think there's a lot of money on
the riverboat a lot of money and tralana
he's investigating for us he says to
meet him at the tailor's okay one big
score down here Arthur and we disappear
we are almost heading home where is home
I don't know exactly but I can smell it
I'm gonna go investigate this trolley
thing old Bronte was talking about okay
okay boss and you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna contemplate whether or not I
have a choice here cuz maybe you got a
choice Oh going for a specific thing or
a different thing I'm not a hundred
percent sure also did I have bullets
here what the hell oh no I had bullets
here
no no if they're any good bullets if I'm
supposed to have you bullets but got
bullets now my guys taking taking taking
taking this there's overlap a little bit
of column a a little bit of column B I
don't know why I need all this stuff but
I guess it's because I guess I'd never
really do this so maybe it all just
stocked up I mean I did upgrade the gun
station to maximum let's throw knives oh
yeah can I take those no I can't have
any more all right never mind then
alright boss where we go where we be
what we do what we see
balls buzz well Bob also heard my
pussy's right boss I thought you were
out here but I don't exactly know which
way you went boss but alright let's look
at the map what have we got going on
here
I imagine that we're gonna look for
everything and then eventually we're
gonna get what we need what is that
stranger
I don't know walked because of the
bounty no look at the stranger look at
it yeah I'm gonna look at it are ya
that's fine
all right night of the fine night of
debauchery meet him at the tailor's I've
just got clothes I discard clothes you
know before I go to the tailor I'm gonna
go to the barber cuz screw all of you
and thinking that I'm not good enough
god damn it god damn it I look so
goddamn fashionable and all these people
think it's not good enough
well you're not cutting out for me
you're not good enough for anything
especially not me not good enough for my
hat yeah how are you doing over there
there's a lot of horses because we have
a lot of people but that's a lot of
horses can I plead their No go bulls
really gotta go stop and go about it I
won't be ice won't be let's go get him
let's show these guys who's boss today
are certainly not the boss I am the boss
of this I am the boss of this place and
the Baba to hunt some Gators as soon as
I find like a like a like guy a trapper
down here wait wrong turn we're oh gosh
boy
that's my boy this that's my boy all
right boy that's my boy
sure I didn't mean it why shut up just
cuz I got a bear hat doesn't mean you
got to be scared you big baby
shut up all these guys suck you suck I
suck stop complainin horsey air boy
look we're going to a nice dry attaboy
going into sound denial I know I they
call it that all the time not good old
st. Dennis like it should be excuse me
watch it you watch me don't watch your
face oh yeah that's right I punched that
guy I forgot about that I need to go to
the post office before ever anybody
allowed me okay I'm gonna go to the post
the office the office oh there but I
can't go there
cuz it's I don't know why why can't I go
there why can't I go I can go to I can
go to the tailor right can I go to the
barber barber I can go to the barber I'm
gonna go the barber these guys can't
tell you I'm going to the barber left
hello are you doing hey oh you phone
nice beardo gonna get rid of mine but
screw you why are you throwing hey are
you doing nice car hey are you doing are
you doing hey coppers don't look at me
ah look at me so closely just gonna
skedaddle hurry okay are you doing you
should go see that know what ooh hi what
yeah hit somebody I hit somebody
Dodge's hit somebody I have no idea when
I go in this barber home and change my
appearance like in my well so goddamn
much let's do facial hair first okay
let's do let's do a nice the English
the Maltese the Burnside the soup save
the goatee the Josiah leg Oh mutton is
that what my face looks like that's
awful pendant hey Brendon all right
French Fork weird spork Spartan okay
done dreary it's weird
Spartan like that hey I think that
that's yeah your words didn't match your
mouth and you're just having a mustache
so you you're just saying that but that
that's more like it now that Oh hahaha
I'm into that but hang on let's get
something else the verity the Picador
ray oh the big all the Picador a fork
Dutchman
well these all suck oh that I could look
like Dutch oh I could look like Dutch I
know I gotta go with the big honkin
mustache oh yes
give me the what I know I don't know how
sharp tacks are but I like my moustache
it's very very nice okay let's get my
hair done some kind of normal here all
right Stiles left parted parted side
aren't I prim and proper middle parted
oh nice little parted fade right parted
swept back buzz no oh pomade oh oh keep
the length but make it a nice dapper
look you know oh we there's nobody here
sir there's nobody but you and me in
this weird place we are our length hair
could do it back a bit all right let's
first put some pomade in this bad boy I
like the pomade well it's pretty decent
I look right spiffy if I do say so
myself and I do say a lot of myself
there's a fade there I don't need to
fade maybe I do need to fade I don't
like to fade right parted Fame man
looking mighty handsome mighty handsome
that is a handsome man but if I do this
if I do the fade it's not gonna have the
pomade it looks like it might have a bit
of a pomade on it my god I've never seen
him like that we say your hair is your
first impression okay now this is what I
call a handsome bear wearing man well
you won't believe this but a lady came
in with a poodle the other day I said
I'm a good barber but I got a trout a
line somewhere
I'll take it
that's me put some pomade in that bad
boy give me some more pomade just give
me all the pomade you got just like fill
my bag with pomade never even heard the
word pomade before but and some son of a
[ __ ] give me my bear
let my bear on my head put the berry
there it is yeah it didn't even matter
what I had on the hair I got a bear
thank you really
indeed thank you all right boy let's go
make a date with destiny here who do we
got going on there's another name on my
list I wasn't there before what this
what do you mean I was question mark
that was that was not a question mark
before if I gotta get more clothes I'm
gonna be real pissed who's this Sadie
Adler Sadie needs to speak with me well
Sadie's gonna have to wait because I got
business over here okay whatever you say
man though you don't mind me cutting
through here do you boss
schools school okay wait a minute
yeah hello oh I guess I'm here hey I bet
you barely recognize me whoever I'm
talking to we're going to need to get
you smarten up a bit
why well you can't play at the tables
and a lot of us a riverboat looking like
this yeah not if you want to fit in so
well that no one will realize you're
there to rob the place now come on are
we still doing that muff cause we're
going to fix you up so fine no one will
notice a thing
I just good please
it's just really just gonna be the
episode of me did clothes what I just
got clothes
in need of a new suit no I'm not on the
riverboat where's my tie I had a tie you
find all my inventory in the catalog
here make this gentleman look like the
Duke he really is
it was the english's fault is
grandfather had to emigrate a bitter and
jealous people you can see the
aristocrat in his profile that picture
from all the hidden breeding might I
suggest the fine three-piece town suit
sir perfect for the occasion I'd say
gamma bear no my bear bear at least get
another suit as the only suit ingenious
actually what is the action he has
planned
indeed it's not much of an action you'll
play cards and win and you're going to
bet very big and clairvoyantly while you
and everyone's going to think you're
some new monies from the oil fields come
to lay it on thick drunk all the while
hair Strauss will be signaling you in
your line of sight when you bust the
place they'll take you upstairs to pay
you off and that is when Xavier comes in
and you take whatever you want you don't
think they might see an armed Mexican
coming into the safe with mnsure they
might but perhaps not you will see the
suspense is killing me
don't don't be so jaded we both know
this is just the kind of innocent fun
thrive on after the past couple of
months
armed robbery don't seem such an
innocent pastor no oh but we you all of
us will be done here oh come on I have
never been more upset at someone trying
to give me free [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
and you could you smarten up my dear
hick friend here oh I was just here or
gentlemanly deportment well very good
sir no it's not good good at all not if
they're gonna let him play big at the
tables tonight
and I'm done thank you that was great
thank you very much
how do I look sit down sit down there's
it's alright it is alright it is alright
isn't it well I'm glad you paid for that
buddy because I rant him right out of
business which reminds me
no shuffling a mumbling pop your chest
outside yourselves so whose am our
driver oh yes don't worry George and I
go way back
it's a man called Desmond fly made of
fortunate things always keep some extra
collateral in the safe upstairs
so if Strauss sitting hand here
Valentino what cards akka he won't but
the dealer has recently become a very
good friend of mine good fortune he'll
make sure you get the right cards what
could possibly go wrong
Doh okay all right this is gonna go good
in my play with I got money
your chips boobie wait come on well
ain't this just to back Nix okay sure
whatever searches we get on George
very good sir thank you George
good luck sir thank you I guess I won't
be needing it cuz everything's rigged
watch Strauss oh okay you got it
I hope you don't mind that I'm a that
Smee
hello that's me sham bagging a for
everybody I'm afraid we require all
patrons to hand over their guns and it
our income was done the tables of wait
I'll go find myself a change of clothes
without a gun okay all right then
hey hey for me okay all right good to
see you
you aim to please we all have good
mustaches for that guy
[Music]
okay sorry boys I'm taking it all we'll
see about that really you guys are all
you what you guys are all you guys are
all - Blythe wins with three queens you
guys are all out then may the best
moustache I would stick to oil mr.
Callaghan I don't think you have a
future on the stage well I'm going to
call you I know how to play poker I know
I know I know both of real good well
what have we got Strauss listen listen
listen I think you me together on this
one you me us we're gonna blast it wait
wouldn't all-in be like literally
everything of my ogre oh yeah yeah suck
it is that it yeah well maybe you
shouldn't have gone all then when you
didn't have anything done first
something else to play with meaning well
I heard doing some big boys on this boat
maybe that's not you know fan sit your
hillbilly ass down why I got a watch
look at you an expensive one
real fine Swiss a roiling are no less
ruling the safe upstairs it's worth more
than you okay I just now play as you
wish all right let's do this again of
course we've crossed bass I was
fortunate enough to tour little
operation heads up a new handle haha
waste any more time oh well that was
worried sir everyone is the author of
his own good fortune and what am i the
author of okay alright well listen
listen listen listen listen listen
listen listen listen listen I'm talking
you let me talk I smell what The Rock is
cooking oh oh oh [ __ ] lines mister blind
mr. Callahan wins with an ace damn you
no offense now forgive my lack of
discretion but uh where might I find
this watch it's upstairs shall we go and
have a look
that was well setup if anything could be
just considered a lucky win that was a
lucky win I started last week
[Music]
of course two hands two hands man this
guy is just a bag of Dreams here what a
lovely person
imma feel so bad when I clobber you in
the back of the skull a little feel real
bad about it although I'm gonna take his
gun
hey pit boss would take your gun I'm a
wallaby
yes you're right only an idiot would
give a greaser a gun sorry okay maybe I
should have punched that guy out already
all right let's get out of here
yeah probably look no one heard that gun
bang Bomi
no one heard the bang boom
and how exactly are we getting out of
here I ain't too sure this is what tends
to happen when you leave Chelonia in
charge of planning Oh garnish no meat
probably involve us dressing up as
dancing girls can't Canyon off the side
I like that form by the way Thanks give
anyone a job these days so we know we
need to maybe we could still blend into
the crowd when it all goes crazy which
it surely will all right okay I guess
let's go to the bar I did have fun Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
business do we got some business here
[Music]
[Music]
okay well I guess this is happening now
okay alright wait hang on oh my goodness
[Music]
I guess I shouldn't laugh that it was a
good shy I guess who's there
oh come on pick a bowl a little higher
oh come on now oh come on now oh come on
okay this is how we're gonna do this now
[Music]
but I didn't even see that one
[Music]
[Music]
Podolski are you
well that was close to me who showed me
oh I see
[Music]
what okay let's go let's go let's go
what's up there
when we're doing background shoot people
oh I get it okay I get it I get it
running like babies hope what about the
alligator dolls but that's far you think
they're gonna spot us
they might know we're here my shoot
they might know they can turn the boat
around
I guess the fine so how much did we get
a few thousand I think pretty good yes
indeed
and this watch apparently it's worth a
bunch of Swiss a roiling um dice watch
yes it's alright letting go all right
we'll give it back down
alright come on let's get out of here
yeah well that wasn't as big a score as
we were really hoping for I think we
were trying to go for the bank shall we
go for a bank
maybe Bank it's a good dulcet tone you
got going on there why are we listening
to it
oh the bank oh good I got my hat back
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that's a the holy
[ __ ] that was a lot of money
swoop are you tired you you you cold you
tired and cold I guess that's all there
is then okay all right well where we
going next
this one's all exit out I still need to
get myself paid off I can go here pay
off my dead let me go ahead and do that
before I do anything else because it's
just gonna cause me troubles I know that
man I know I don't rob people on my own
just because I'm like yeah it'll be bad
for my karma but at the same time it
sure is easier to rob people than try to
be legit this game but man I just feel
so bad about it if it wasn't scripted
I'm sorry
oh I'm fine apparently hello how are you
I'm gonna pay my bounty sure don't ease
okay I don't know what you said to me
but I'm sure it was an insult all right
now we got to go where we got to go
where are we going
whatever this stranger isn't supposed to
be part of this it's either go see the
stranger go back and see Sadie Adler
who's probably gonna get into some
trouble Galloway Galloway jump on
Galloway I knew that was gonna be done
so let's go see the stranger first cuz
right here and then once the train
stations open up for some reason because
they're not we'll go see jimboy Callaway
because I am NOT gonna ride all the way
up there no way no how no way no how
they ain't gonna never do that
never doing that I never do that I never
do that we never do that put a glue take
our pan tiger pamphlet what did it sales
strategy you have there man take a
pamphlet oh yeah you know I wish someone
told me you're old
so when you told me that earlier it sure
would have been good convince me a lot
of things watch it here we go in 3 2 1 I
believe we've met that guests the party
Oh Evelyn Miller
unfortunately so like my Hatter
Arthur Morgan at least sometimes can I
say something rude sure the mayor thinks
you robbed him
Oh to be clear he wasn't very upset
about it he rather liked you okay do you
were wanting to say can you steal things
is there a reason you're asking me to
incriminate myself mr. Miller I'm sorry
have you met this is rains fall a great
chief and his son eagle flies Joan we
saw you on the wagon train crossing the
river at Cumberland Falls and at the
party you were upstairs you have great
powers of observation as my people if we
are even a people anymore we've fought
hard we've made peace treaties and those
treaties were broken and we've been
moved and punished and punished and
moved I'm sure and now I am told we are
to be moved again clearly contravening
the peace treaty signed three years ago
this will lead to war no my son
we could not fight another war they have
got stronger and we have become far
weaker mr. Morgan
bad business it's to do with oil I know
it is but I need the proof I believe
there were some prospectors who were on
their land a few months ago who have
filed reports with laviticus Cornwall in
the state government claiming huge
reserves of oil under their land so you
want me to try and steal it obviously
they can't and even more obviously I
would be useless
listen I've realized that it is a
ridiculous request
we're very desperate I'm not a do-gooder
mr. Miller
gentlemen I'm very sorry for your
predicament but I'm a working man I got
problems of my own
we will tell you very handsomely mr.
Morgan how much I told you they're all
mercenary what's turn around there's a
price on my head in two states my friend
the government doesn't like me any more
than it does you
like you I've been running for as long
as I can remember and like you my time
here is Nayan done we understand and we
will pay thank you you meet my son in a
couple of days near Citadel Rock just
west of the oil fields okay we are very
grateful for your help
gentlemen an appointment with the
senator we should head over there
so waste of our time in is we must try
everything come along
man real Negative Nancy over there mr.
Miller the counselor wants to apologize
if you can see you now we've been
waiting I don't know how long or next
month if you'd like to reschedule come
perhaps the senator won't mind waiting
things are looking up and up for you
guys I can't believe that's the same
like people that were on the mountain
it's the same people at the very
beginning of the game the second episode
we're looking on the Overlook that's the
same people that's crazy that's so cool
that's so weird alright so I don't know
why everything's still locked off I
don't know when these stagecoaches get
locked off and makes no sense to me no
stable all right so we got a stranger
over here but it don't matter cuz I
ain't gonna do nothing about that we're
gonna go over here hopefully by the time
we get done with Sadie Adler we're gonna
have ourselves a real good time I'm
sorry hi I'm sorry I'm sorry
hey you mind where you're going you
weren't looking at me neither yours you
were the one that was not paying
attention therefore it's not my problem
is your problem anyway so now that we
got that under way we're gonna go see
Sadie Adler who's gonna have to show us
a real good time
probably robbing somebody and then yeah
it'll be progress you need me a suck
something a do you need me a suck I can
shock sure can suck hello what kind of
medicine come on I suck this out myself
help did you have what are you doing
trying random plants flowers
steer clear thanks mister oh okay well
does that sentence have any meaning for
you this one where does all bland right
here this one oh this little guy ain't
no problem about that
ain't nothing wrong come on you're just
up you're just a piece of [ __ ] huh
here's just a little eat wait
it's that eat hang on wait try it for
myself
yeah where's this where's this where's
is hang on where's this give me another
one it's daddy I'm gonna find one I'm
gonna eat it I'm gonna shove it inside
Maga there's more all buffet that guy
was just a pansy you can't handle this
[Music]
that guy was a big bubble-blowing [ __ ]
baby that guy what a big baby
well hon a big baby waterbed I can't
even eat this one I know what it does
for me but it definitely doesn't do what
he was saying big old baby I had was
delicious my eyes are you boy oh I think
my days in polite society are over well
I just saw Bill Williamson at a party at
the Sandinistas mayor's house
if he can do it anyone can you get any
leaks
yeah I think so you know so Arthur
Morgan ha boss We Need to Talk okay boss
like that will you excuse us you gonna
let me come Robin with you do it my lord
a few more like her we can take over the
whole world few more like her there
won't be much of a world left yes
perhaps now the trolley bus station I
went down there I took a look at it I
think we can hit it I never robbed in a
city before well you leave the planning
to me you'll ride with me always is it
just you mate no we'll need one more I
reckon I say Lenny
now Myka well that depends if you want a
massacre or a payday
no I wish there was something I could do
to make the tool you get along better
well that's easy make him change yeah oh
oh oh my god holy [ __ ] what the hell
what the hell that's messed up man
up one down two down oh right in the
kidney oh and down
[Music]
Oh 10 not down oh this guy's tough pop
not that tough all right okay then geez
I'll get to the front door I'll get to
the front door right okay all right then
I'm going for the front door charge out
of aah okay okay here we go here we go
here we go here we go n come on this let
me get some cover here let me get some
cover and cover and cover
[Music]
bribed him
whoa hey John are you going to run for
it or something
why don't you all got bags on your head
a new fashion saving
at one
[Applause]
neither one
oh god this guy's getting a little too
close on me I'm like that nun boink
Bing bong we're gonna retreat we're
gonna do it oh my god what the [ __ ] you
mean they can hit me in the head
oh I didn't retreat that's what I'm the
problem ah I mean it did hit me in the
head but yeah okay do I need to retreat
now or is that now what I need okay
watch this watch this watch this
oh we got it we got it we got it I got
them oh yeah I got okay all right I got
it boss I got it you gotta boss you guys
boss got it
over there Oh huh
I feel I shan't Ibiza belong I didn't
even know what Kieran was up to where
sale yet I'm gone I'm gone
sandy here we go all-carbon sandy I'm
coming
stay anywhere
yep
and butter ah stupid box just cuz I feel
like you deserve more bullets I'm gonna
give you more
got'em all right back towards a house
you got it [ __ ] all over you
I'm out I think we're wait and I need
some sweet tobacco
got him what are you talking about you
said go back to the house behind there I
feel
okay did you move
oh he's dead not today okay I think so
except for Karen here poor kid
mr. Swanson would you take this boy and
bury him someplace near but not too near
of course Charles help me with the box
we need to get this place cleaned up mr.
Pearson miss Grimshaw already taking
care of it come on now work no one else
was shot risk really hate so can i order
it so can i we need to get moving away
from here so we should start looking for
another camp you ain't thinking big
enough
Arthur you ain't seeing the vastness of
our problems and our opportunities I'm
not sure I guess you will son will meet
me here's the trolley station
we got work all right boss you got it
boss show here for you boss here for you
you got in my pants my pants a grand my
that's better but my pants are pretty
good okay so what are we doing here
what's the vastness of our problems boss
saved my life and I could not save his
mrs. Adler felt braver than any of us
she is driven by powerful forces I
scarcely understand that's what love has
done to her I guess
well it's very poetic of you to write I
wish I had a journal I should probably
start a journal I mean I did kind of
start one on tumblr but it's not a real
journal or is it is that even written by
me I don't know hey miss Adler Oh am I
not supposed to be following you for
some reason I thought it was good to be
following you miss Adler that's rich
from you
maybe you should maybe you feel like I'm
you're like washing clothes I'm all
right see it okay
what would happen if I just what happens
if you play this game like a douche like
Micah he's go around act agonising
everybody all right I guess that's that
then
good okay you seem well river yes
well maybe I've been okay before but
then I make a fool of myself again so do
i I went into town so did I if I was
still a religious man I'd say there are
too many Catholics there but I've given
up on all that me too driver
I met a monk they're kindly fellow to me
back to my B's in college is there any
purpose to this conversation Reverend
not really but he said the strangest
things old man are bad things happening
in town bad things happening in the city
who would have thought it possible
well maybe if you're there you could
have a chat with them he's hanging about
outside the marketplace collecting alms
for the poor
[Music]
okay Thank You Reverend I guess I'll
keep that in mind here hey how you doing
hey how you doing
okay I guess I gotta go see Dutch now I
kind of want to go over and go to gym
boy Callaway don't know how much longer
there's gonna be hey how you doing
lovebirds whistling nobody ever gonna
take him again I swear I was thinking
maybe it would be a little easier for me
to don't just change like the wind
Abigail no Arthur some folks change now
there's just too damn big Abigail is
door blindness the gavel eels don't see
doors you're in a good mood funk I'm
sorry that just caught me completely off
guard all areas seriously I think I
think Dutch might actually be in town so
yeah he's in town okay so I'll be going
the wrong way
hey at least that's open maybe oh but
it's right there I really want to see
about jimboy Calloway because I want to
see if we can see black Bell again Bell
is so cool it was so cool maybe I'll do
that but maybe I won't maybe I will
maybe I want I don't know I'll decide
when I get there
[Music]
here milking the wrong [ __ ] son milk in
the wrong bed that's a metaphor by the
way if you say so
is it a simile I can't remember okay all
right thank you for that uncle you're
just always so enlightening every
conversation with you just uh a bag full
of Dreams and sunshine and rainbows
thank you for being you anyway I'm going
to town I'll see you around peacock
that's a turkey not judge vanderlin I
might be coming towards you seeing a bit
should I do this
oh god I should have I should have done
something about that that's no good well
now everybody yeah I should have done
something sooner I feel uncomfortable
about that I mean it's not my fault they
shot the guy but my inaction led to one
last death I had him dead in my sights
and I just didn't do anything about it I
was unsure fish [ __ ] about that cuz save
that man 11 yet I didn't and then I
killed him anyway even though I could
have walked away then would that have
been better or worse trying to run from
my horse I'm here contemplating a
philosophical dilemma I don't know what
I'm doing my is my inaction making me
worse but then I killed the guys who
shot the guys and I better or worse for
cut sleeves that dismissive bra whatever
you yelling at out understand or why but
okay you're yellow let's give this
trolley touch of and early come on keep
walking you're late taste in this place
you turned into some clock-watching city
boy what's the urgency
we need to leave forever we've been
doing well making money but for us all
to leave together we need enough for a
boat now I found a friendly ship captain
he's willing to take us to Australia or
to Edie
we just need to pay for passage and give
him money for land when we get there no
questions asked we will disappear be
reborn where the hell is Tahiti South
Pacific an untouched parents don't live
there Tahiti ins I guess we made a bit
of money on that riverboat job but not
enough for us to leave and live
patiently where's the rest coming from
in there so we are gonna rob that place
well I didn't think we was fixing the
plumbing I don't know if you have
noticed but we are on
clock I reckon we got a few days before
the Pinkertons show and then we're done
now we need money come on I got this one
it's your choice all right
there's everything okay thank you
you need to give me all your money now
this is it love nothing else not much
there's nothing really Peter sure yes
get out here company we don't want to
hurt in here this room check the safe I
will check the center I'm gonna do it
I'm doing it where's the safe is this to
save I don't think they keep much cash
in their opening not much but it's
something
totally worth it boss good job we really
scored good there's almost nothing here
there should be stacks of cash in there
he told us there was look against no
stacks a few dollars and cause that's it
then we got a problem there's a ton of
cops out there
thank you seemed like a good time for
sarcasm do you are through gentlemen
something you try perfect it's so fast
they'll never catch us landing speed
kick it up into Maximum Overdrive Lenny
bottoms up
all right we go hang on wait couple and
they'll never notice the guy with a bear
on his head hang on wait let's check out
let's not be so hasty
sorry who did that who you think you are
where where how do I do the swap aside
zoos swap in the side wall but you are
gonna get a shot the next you are gonna
shine get shot nog and there we go
I guess I got that let me get some June
2 backe well that was his fault
now I every cop in the city is going get
shot
the laws got away with me now speed it
up the bear controls activated I have
two bullet holes in my mask
a high-speed collision we must have been
going 25 30 miles an hour
Oh bear stamina activate Oh bear healing
oh well here we go
all right come on down hey where's mine
where's my tabacky where's my cocaine
hey yeah yeah that's not nice
what else I got is this it I'm gonna go
double wheel D I'm going through bull
wheels here we go who's there who's
there who's there
[Music]
okay let's move why are we moving why
are we moving
got him wave unlimited that I while I do
this I got a lot up I got a lot of
I got a lot of shot of that off
bullet holes in my mass go we're going I
don't know where we're going woof we do
okay I'm here hello all right
come on
and do other than guns is a lot worse
sometimes please Dutch okay has he been
shot boss
[Music]
I'm going back to one I can't do this
I'm a good gun
I lost my good gun yeah I'm better with
one that I am with two it keeps moving
all over the place with two of them
although it's I think it's moving all
over the place now anyway my hat
wait you son of a [ __ ] you shot my hat
with my word
rare finding at least I please have
please let's go let's go let's go I'm
going I'm going I'm going
damn it damn it damn you damn you damn
you but then so wobbly just cuz after
the after the crash we got some minor
brain damage that my hand is going all
over the place
[Music]
oh god I need some cover can you afford
me some cover buddy all right Lenny
watch out okay you got it boss
oh well that was good shot that's a good
shot okay
we're getting in what are we doing am i
driving all right
Oh
how are you Oh God [ __ ] what the hell
[Music]
there we go now I'm getting rhythms back
probably cuz I'm sitting down we can on
real life obviously Oh Fifi okay there
we go all right this was a good job
everybody there they'll never suspect
anything insane tonight they won't know
for [ __ ] who we are what we do oh yeah
we'll just throw it at him oh yeah good
job lighten that boss
holy [ __ ] oh wait wait wait wait wait I
will now remain in debt I went firing
without any targets we did it boss I
feel so proud of us do we do so good
okay well that was good on us we did
good but now we'll never be welcome in
st. than that I again I think we're
clear where's my happy
you know what touch next time let's not
damn discretion seems like a good lead I
know well we made it thanks to you don't
mention it yeah good kid we've got
fifteen dollars and a quarter
don't forget the quarter shut up Arthur
he set us up played me like it Yoko put
the law on us what do we do to him what
did I do to him I guess he thinks he's
the king round here you don't want to
like see you so what are we doing next
judge well I know what we're doing it we
just need money
one more decent take and we're gone the
bank is our bet Hosea agrees especially
I don't feel so good now you just got a
bash on the head come on I'm taking you
back to camp
hey you did real good there Lenny just
wish it could have turned out better
well
can't win them all you're just gonna
leave me stranded out of your way well
my way well uh okay I guess I'm just
gonna be here then thanks for that
horsey are you here twill be Swope oh
please tell me you picked up my hat
please tell me you yeah there's mad
there we go that feels good boy yes a
good boy
okay that's gonna do it for this episode
of Red Dead Redemption - thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you're enjoying it so far I know I am as
far as like progress in the story I'm
not harm percent sure forty six percent
but that doesn't mean that we're gonna
do 100% completion but 46 percent we've
got a long way to go so thank you
everybody so much and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye